j'ai déjà vu le monde du loch ness oui
oui vous ne croyez pas vous avez raison
[Musique]
le loch ness un lac situé dans les
highlands en écosse très célèbre pour
son fameux monstre on voit même lui
donne un petit nom mais si la première
grande photo qu'on voit apparaître
arrive en 1933
on y voit ce qui serait le monstre du
loch ness
mais la plus connue elle date de 1934
elle fait le tour du monde et plusieurs
journaux vont la reprendre et s'en
saisir pour dire que voilà nessie existe
pour vrai qu'est ce qui va se passer un
bout du tourisme les gens veulent venir
en écosse pour voir le fameux monstre
pourquoi est-ce que c'est dans ces
années là dans les années 1930 qu'on
voit beaucoup de photos du fameux
monstre du loch ness
ben ce qu'il faut dire c'est qu'on
assiste à une compétition féroce en
différents journaux pour trouver la
bonne image la meilleure image donnée si
donc les gens sont prêts à tout pour
produire cette fameuse photo à tout même
à faire défaut et c'est faux love on est
exposé très rapidement on veut le savoir
on va dire dans la première c'est un
labrador avec un bout de bois dans la
seconde main c'est quelqu'un que traille
est une espèce de coup de dinosaure dans
du bois qu'il le fait aller comme ça sur
le lac et tout le monde va dire ben ou
et tout ça est faux sauf que ça existe
encore aujourd'hui des gens qui croient
dur comme fer que le monstre du loch
ness existe
internet va provoquer une explosion de
l'exposition donné si dans l'espace
public
en 2007 on rapporte qu on a une vidéo
qui montre que des mouvements sous marin
donc pour certains ça serait la preuve
que non et s'ils existent en 2011
on parle même d'une image type montre
hors de tout doute que nessie existe des
fonds de l'impression de revenir dans
les années 30 on dirait qu'avec
l'histoire du loch ness on est encore là
dedans et si on remarque les recherches
que l'on fait sur google on apprend
qu'en 2015 il y aurait plus de 200 mille
demandes pour savoir si le monstre du
loch ness existe bel et bien
bref mais s'ils ont une longue vie
devant elle
même si elles existent pas